now whatever your political views
whatever your race or ethnic background
wherever you live these past three
months have tested you in some way the
coronavirus deaths that lockdowns
massive job losses education disruptions
loneliness depression and then just when
we were turning the corner protests
unrest violence the death of an unarmed
black man it all spilled out coast to
coast after that senseless killing of
George Floyd now many of you wonder if
it's even fixable at this point I've
been hearing from you and given how much
anger flashes on the screen every day
and every night and so many using a
tragic death is permission dilute and
even assault innocent business owners
and law enforcement the honest feeling
of its sadness and righteous anger over
Floyd's death that could be channeled
into positive dialogue it's just
overshadowed by destruction and chaos
and Tifa and their allies they're on a
mission and it ain't about justice it's
not about George Floyd they want to
abolish our rights under the
Constitution and they want to rewrite
our history they want us to hate our
country like they hate our country now
today to clear my head what I did is
that went on a bike ride I know that
sounds frivolous at a time like this but
I had to clear my head is one of those
days and I took my oldest son around the
north side of the National Mall but what
I saw when I was there made me want to
cry I've lived here for 30 years and the
only time before today that I saw
National Guard troops around our
national monuments was after 9/11 but
there they were dozens of them
guarding the Lincoln Memorial the Korean
War Memorial the Vietnam Memorial and
the World War Two memorial now a few
days earlier the World War Two memorial
had been vandalized with spray paint for
the extremists radicals nothing not even
a place of honor such as this is sacred
well once again they misread the
American people these sites and what
they represent
whom they honor are sacred to us so what
did we do well my son and I we stopped
and we said a short prayer and then I
proceeded to thank every member of the
guard that we came upon and I told each
and everyone how much we appreciated
them it was a cross-section of America
african-american men and women serving
alongside white men and women mostly
young they were keeping watch as runners
tourists stream by some protesters but
it was quiet now presumably they're more
worried about what happens at night
tonight in Washington and we hope for
the best when those brave spray-paint
militants come out to desecrate and
destroy of course none of them know what
real sacrifice is for if they did they'd
be doing something positive with their
lives the way forward for the rest of us
though requires that we get back to the
basics we don't need a new normal we
just need normal because normal
Americans want a fair and just society
where the rule of law applies equally to
all people regardless of race normal
Americans are disgusted by the killing
of George Floyd normal Americans think
the current situation is so out of
control that the US military needs to be
called in to bring order to the streets
check out this new morning consult poll
showing 58% support calling in the
troops to aid state and local police
including nearly half of the Democrats
now the same party it's been promising
African Americans better lives for
decades our first African American
president was propelled into office not
once but twice with the majority of a
white support yet when it comes to
delivering actual results including for
African Americans despite what you hear
in the media despite everything you
heard just today in the media Donald
Trump has done better than anyone before
the coronavirus most jobs created went
to women and minorities seven million in
total most of those women in minority
black Americans
their lowest unemployment numbers ever
increased homeownership school choice
criminal justice reform creation of
opportunities owns those weren't
hashtags or slogans
those are real policies that people
worked really hard on to deliver real
results Joe Biden was in the Senate for
what 30 years it was VP 4:8 and all he
can come up with now are symbolic
gestures slogans hashtags professions of
empathy they're fine but they don't
create jobs they do not create
opportunity but they can create the
illusion of caring
I won't traffic in fear and division
I won't fan the flames of hate I'll seek
to heal the racial wounds that have long
plagued our country this job is not
about me it's about you it's about us we
are in the battles of a civilization
he's been saying the same thing for
decades and he's done nothing and if he
and Obama knew how to deliver all that
that he just said they would have
delivered what he said during their two
terms in office now I understand for a
lot of people Trump may be rough around
the edges they sometimes don't like his
tone or tweets or his bravado might turn
you off at times but he's worked harder
with better results than any politician
I know
I've ever met to bring prosperity to all
people and as especially wants
prosperity for the african-american
community and remember it's a
working-class people at the core of his
America first movement the rich elites
they won't they almost do it from Wall
Street in the Hollywood they voted for
Hillary and they're going to vote for
Biden and by the way those are the same
people many of them never Trump urse by
the way who thought outsourcing jobs to
China was a grand idea and they're the
same ones who sought to keep foreign
workers flooding into the country
including illegal immigrants all of them
are for Jill Biden the America first
movement you know it's never gonna have
a lot of celebrities
but it has something better it has
policies that lead to prosperity for
more people and the more prosperous you
are most of the time the less resentful
you will be and the more peace you will
have we want that for all people and
when Biden supporters say they you know
think about they say when they want to
defund or even abolish the police ask
yourself for a moment
who's that really gonna help who will be
the victims of those crimes that go
unprosecuted working-class and
disadvantaged people that's who because
the rich people the ones are gonna vote
for Biden they can hire their own
security but everybody else is just
gonna end up more vulnerable and less
safe
that's how that'll roll we've seen
evidence of this by the way during the
past week when cops were nowhere to be
found
[Music]
president Trump has demonstrated that he
will work with anyone of any party in
any state any time to help more people
get out of poverty and that includes by
the way reforming institutions to ensure
that everyone gets a fair shot but that
process doesn't require burning it all
down or creating a perpetual grievance
culture like the one that exists on
college campuses that'll just set
everybody back at a time one normal
America wants to take a step forward and
that's the angle